before joe rogan was a hit podcast host
and after ludacris was a hit rapper they
were hosts of a show called fear factor
do not try any of these at home i'm
watching for medical accuracy and
information only
oh my god worst fear alert of my life oh
my god forget about the little pinchers
the tail just going
calm down calm down oh my god tries to
put them in there they're biting her
hands no
if aliens were ever to come down to
earth and see this they would feel pity
on us one of you will be bound by your
wrists while covered in over a hundred
thousand beads 1000
is going to have to eat 20 live bees i'm
more afraid for the bees
what did the bees do to deserve oh my
god i would have a forget panic attack
this is dangerous getting stung by bees
causes localized inflammatory response
if you have an anaphylactic reaction you
could die
all right here comes the first bee down
there oh my god what happens when you
eat a bee can it sting you or those
stingless bees
that's it nice okay she's not out of
harm's way yet it's not nice
how do you get them off of her did she
get stung show me a sting they didn't
show removing them entirely ah i wonder
i wonder if those were stingless bees
oh no being submerged
worst feeling ever these challenges
always scared the life out of me because
if they like drown they're gonna need
life support quick and remember when
you're doing chest compression on
someone who's drowning very different
than doing chest compressions at people
who are on land you only need to do
hands-only cpr if you find someone down
on land but drowning you need to give
rescue breaths start with rescue breaths
hold on marissa's in trouble marissa's
in trouble don't know
bree
they are struggling to breathe yeah it's
hard to breathe cause all the little
things are going in your mouth
she's just breathing she's not even
participating in the task she's like i'm
just gonna live here
oh this is scary
what's about to happen i get like a
little bit anxious like if i do look
down normal human emotion this is not a
phobia you're hanging off like a spider
at the bottom of a helicopter and you're
afraid normal fear nothing medically
wrong with this
oh what is this a bungee jump off a
helicopter that feels dangerous can you
imagine if she just like bungee
jumped all the way over the helicopter
onto the blades that would have been an
evil bungee jumping is dangerous because
that recoil can cause like snapping of
the neck if it's not secure and you know
snapping of the neck is never ideal
inside this box are over
500 bull testicles i watched this
episode with my parents when we came as
immigrants from russia and we're like
what is happening in america on go your
partner is going to smash their face
into this box of testicles
on nationwide television your partner
has to smash their face into a box of
testicles i don't even know if there's
any harm here like medically what if the
cow had an sti maybe that could be a
problem like an epididymitis
this is what an epididymitis looks like
your partner will then have to spit out
that testicle into the testicle
receptacle
who made what five year old made this
stunt
all right missy she's got a testicle
oh going from upside down very nicely
done when you're changing position like
that the blood flow is going to your
brain then it's going to your feet to
your brain that could be really
disorienting
you got it we're not losing we're not
losing this poor dude is
getting drowned with bull nuts in his
mouth only in america
go
what are we drinking tomato juice
habanero oh spicy sauce all in it all in
there oh did he just throw up it tastes
like van damme punched me in my throat
john called randy i've got his butt
kicked in real life at least do like
chuck norris or something oh he picked
all really really hot peppers come on
baby this is gonna hurt as soon as it
got in my throat i felt it the capsaicin
right there is just bounding to the
receptors making it feel like burning
damage is happening you're getting
full-on inflammatory response swelling
sweating
i can't let him down but my body isn't
going to agree with what's going on yeah
it's not going to agree and you know
what it's going to burn on the way out
too
oh look there's bear
oh that's a scary challenge
[Music]
i assume that's a puncture proof vest
but you would still feel the pressure
and get severe bruising you could even
fracture a bone this way
that was the worst anti-climactic ending
you made it through she almost lost her
arm there
oh right in the bull testicle would you
ever bite a person's arm like that i
would never do that
safety officer will release the canister
of gas and let's see how long you can
stay in the building interesting tear
gas okay so most tear gas isn't actually
gas it's like aerosolized solids or
liquids that cause maximal irritation
it's like bromo something that cause
mucous membrane disruption nausea visual
changes there's actually long lasting
effects to tear gas that's why they
really try and avoid using it
yeah it's very irritating to the airways
oh that's gonna hurt oh
you could have a full on asthma attack
respiratory distress oh
she's gonna need to get washed she could
throw up it doesn't end there like she
needs to take a full decontamination
shower
one of you will be strapped into this
electric chair okay
why
four of the five keys inside that ballet
box unlocks the restraint on this chair
freeing your partner and if you don't
please don't tell me you get
electrocuted if you hit the sides of
this fence you will be electrocuted oh
my god is it like operation the dark
version of operation by the way
electrocuted used to mean electricity
and executed so i really hope no one
dies on pure factor every 15 to 20
seconds the person inside of this chair
will be electrocuted as well stop saying
electrocute just say taste electricity
is dangerous it can stop the heart it
could cause the heart to fibrillate
which is not a useful rhythm you can
actually get skin burns from electricity
so it really depends on the amount of
current how high the voltage is how long
it's being passed through your body also
depends if your skin is wet or dry like
all those things matter
and she got tattoos before so you know
she can handle some paint in that tank
are electric eels containing over a
thousand volts grab six electric eels
and transfer them over to the other side
of the tent you gotta hold them eels
medically i don't know if this is okay
like if my patient's a doctor i'm here
to get clearance in order to touch eels
with my bare hands i would say please
leave office right now
you just gotta commit
guys i'm committing
i haven't even done that this is awkward
no it's just a big baby he should touch
one i want to feel it go ahead grab the
big fat one
don't touch it
[Music]
now he's got to suck 30 leeches off you
before you each eat 10 of them
one
two ew
you know people used to do leech therapy
and there are some things legions are
not terrible for like so when leeches
attach to you they release a chemical
that prevents clotting from happening
because they want to keep sucking your
blood so that chemical can actually be
utilized for certain conditions i don't
recommend using leech therapy on your
own it's more for scientific research
purposes
hurry up you know what's funny i'm
acting grossed out by this but this is
usually how i spend my friday nights
sorry thursday nights
what'd you do last night suck some
leeches off my partner would you do
would you guys have dinner first now at
dinner after the leeches
when i was born oh my god with hundreds
of rats crawling all over me i want to
know because i'm a doctor and i didn't
learn this in school what's the routine
a mouse and a rat rats are bigger oh
what if you have a big mouse like look
look how big this mouse is
is this a rat
sorry i had to do that
thanks for apologizing i felt every
single foot of all those rats oh my god
but rats do transfer a lot of diseases
leptospirosis hantavirus so many issues
salmonella like the bacterialist or huge
bubonic plague how did that happen back
in the day ratas i can't believe i'm
gonna have to be trained up while seeing
my brother suffocating i hope he doesn't
freak out hold on a second did they just
escalate this and make this 10 times
more difficult just going into an
enclosed environment like that would
instantly trigger claustrophobia in most
people claustrophobia is a specific
phobia a lot of people have that your
symptoms will be like nervousness
anxiety all the way up to having a panic
attack and having a pan attack for those
who's ha who's had them basically feels
like the world is ending you can't take
a deep breath your heart's racing all
over the place one minute 30 seconds is
gone you know when there's a stampede at
a mall or a sporting event the real
danger is like putting pressure on your
chest so much so that you can't breathe
that's what i feel like is about to
happen right now this is like my worst
fear and like he's like a human condom
right now
so what happens
[Music]
did he just do chest compressions on him
he's alive you don't need to do that
these are super worms i think super
worms are actually edible and they like
contain some decent protein oh there was
an article in the new york times not too
long ago with super worms because they
could actually digest styrofoam and
plastic and maybe they're a solution to
our recycling dilemmas now what i
thought i would talk about on verified
someone's going to be powerlifting after
this wet one
here we go
this show is disgusting sadists have
created this show and somehow all of
america tuned in you're each gonna have
to walk barefoot on this broken glass
see this is more of a mental thing so
the thing with broken glass is i'm going
to give tips ideally you do this with
wine or champagne bottle because it's
more curved and more gentle the glass
than like if you were to use glass from
a drinking glass and also because
there's so much glass the smaller
particles kind of fall through and allow
a sinking sensation so when you step
it's not as bad as stepping on one piece
of glass
most people don't even cut their feet if
you're doing it correctly
yeah see he's doing the right thing he's
like separating the glass to get the
edges
lift your foot up i don't see it putting
it right in my foot he walked across all
this glass and it only started to hurt
when he stepped on one piece of glass
our strategy is for me to try to eat
most of the marshmallows
what is the marshmallow it's a
marshmallow covered by bees my first
challenge seems doable then you realize
the marshmallows they have to eat are
covered in live flies flies are gross
because not only do they like land on
poop and then land on your food who
knows where these flies have been do you
know how flies eat like if they land on
your watermelon flies puke on your
watermelon first in order to get their
enzymes into the food
i came so close to throwing up there my
eyes are watering how are they eating
that i mean the flies are just protein
so it's fine it's just like society has
ingrained this into my mind oh my god my
eyes are watering devon has two
marshmallows
i'm not faking this
stop showing the zoom ins i'm trying to
give you medical information but all i
can think about is not puking right now
the fda allows some pretty shocking
things in your food click here to check
that out as always stay happy and
healthy this list will surprise you like
it surprised me what the fda said yeah
that's in there cool what
you